hey you can't write this stuff remember
that guy Kris Kobach who I mentioned to
you recently he's the guy who stated or
leaked I guess I don't know the right
phrases that the Trump team is indeed
working on a plan for mandatory
registration to a database of all Muslim
immigrants he's now being considered as
potentially Trump's Department of
Homeland Security Secretary let me say
two key words again from that sick up
Homeland Security okay very important
position very sensitive information that
he could be dealing with literally of
national security importance you know
how we we hear that phrase thrown around
oh this has national security
implications the Department of Homeland
Security absolutely has national
security implications and you just can't
write this stuff the guy who might be
responsible for security of the homeland
didn't even know how to walk around with
his plan for fighting terror covered
maybe in a manila envelope or something
and as you can see in this picture here
over my shoulder of Trump meeting with
Kris Kobach he has this piece of paper
and even from this distantly zoomed out
of view you see that there's a bunch of
writing there and it turns out that you
could very easily zoom in on that and
see what the game plan is it and
remember for four months Trump was
saying you know I'm not gonna give the
plan away that's how you let the
terrorists win I'm gonna just enact the
plan to do it it's all gonna happen
secretly it's all gonna be great well
Kris Kobach your your potential
Secretary of Homeland Security is just
walking around with the plans and it's
been exposed and by the way we can
actually look at what it says and uh a
few of the items on this piece of paper
but Kris Kobach was walking around with
there's a plan to question quote
high-risk immigrants over their support
for Sharia law and the US Constitution a
bullet point says that they will bar the
entry of potential terrorists oh okay
well I guess that's a good idea just
never let the terrorists come into the
country who why wait so simple the paper
that he walked around with calls for an
update and reintroduction of the
National Security entry/exit registry
system originally implemented after 911
it also meant mentions quote extreme
vetting questions for high-risk aliens
and lastly it suggests from what we can
see from just taking a picture of it it
suggests eliminating Syrian refugee
intake or bringing it back down to zero
this would be hilarious if it wasn't so
tragic I mean ask immigrants whether
they support Sharia law sort of silly
because it depends both on people
telling the truth and it ignores the
fact that people like go bak don't think
that people would tell the truth about
that right this isn't new though there's
actually a form called the sf-86 form
which is the questionnaire for national
security positions you can google this
is widely available and it has a
question have you ever knowingly planned
to commit any acts of terror because as
we know Pat every terrorist looking to
get a security clearance to undermine
the United States would just fill out
the form and they would admit if they
were planning to commit acts of terror
wouldn't they know they couldn't
possibly come up with some sort of alias
an alibi to protect what they're
actually out there to do and the the
particularly tragic part is at the
bottom of that page and we can only see
a little bit from the picture there's
something there about voter rolls which
is underlined followed by the word
direct which suggests Direct X
Department to do why there's also a line
which says direct the Department of
Justice and also a line on this
incredibly secret piece of paper that
Kris Kobach walked around in broad
daylight with which says draft amendment
to National Voter dot dot dot talking
about something related to voter rolls
and the voting process the fact that the
potential Homeland Security Secretary is
talking about boating related stuff Pat
is a big red flag well to be fair I mean
this was on a printed out sheet of paper
it wasn't on a private email server yeah
so I mean even though this is clearly
gross negligence I don't think that the
right wing is gonna care so much all I
when I do these stories it's no longer
because I think anybody on the right
might care now or that that ship has
long sailed but it's so that we know
what the hell is going on here we will
take a break what a program we have
for you today warby parker is offering a
free five day home try-on to give you
the opportunity to check out their
glasses i personally wear warby parker
glasses when I'm not wearing my contact
lenses and I also started with one of
these free at home try ons of five pairs
of glasses you can get your free home
try-on and support the david pakman show
at Warby Parker trial dot-com / tdps I
don't really like going into glasses
stores and trying on glasses while the
sales person sort of hovers over me and
I like more than 30 seconds to actually
figure out whether I like the glasses so
with the Warby Parker home try-on I was
able to pick five pairs that i liked put
them on in the comfort of my own home
pick the one I like the most and then
Warby Parker put my prescription lenses
in there for me a lot of people don't
know that the eyeglass industry is
controlled by just a few big
corporations that keep prices very high
like three hundred dollars for
prescription glasses high which is just
insane Warby Parker glasses start at $95
that's what mine cost and for every pair
of glasses sold Warby Parker distributes
a pair of glasses to someone in need you
can try five pairs and see what you like
check out the at-home trial and support
our show by going to Warby Parker
dot-com / TDPS it costs nothing